and joining us with reaction to all of
this is former Ohio Democratic
congressman and current candidate for
Ohio Governor Dennis Kucinich all right
good evening what shall I call you
congressman Dennis may be governor
dennis is fine your honor Oh Touche all
right let's talk about the the border
wall you know one of the issues that
that people have been talking about is
the fact that they think that it doesn't
really serve a purpose and whether it's
a wall or some other kind of
construction you would have to agree
that eighty to ninety percent of the
drugs coming into this country
irrespective of whether there's a market
for these drugs here comes from our
southern border well we want to do
everything we can to stop the drugs from
coming in and to stop them within the
countries that they're coming from
that's true but I'm not a fan of the
border wall George I I think that it's a
waste of money they can accomplish the
same thing with electronic fencing and
that you know we have bridges in Ohio
that are falling down I'd rather see the
money be spent on infrastructure here at
home well would you tell your Democratic
compatriots to or Democrat can Patriots
to go to the table and talk to the
president about infrastructure and you
know taking care of the bridges and the
roads all right look we need a lot of
money to do that it's probably gonna
take a couple trillion dollars and if I
was advising the president I'm not but I
would say put more money in it and build
more let's put America back to work
rebuilding all these bridges and roads
well but but I want to go back a dentist
to the whole issue of the wall versus
the fence you know what we've seen is
billions and billions of dollars I mean
I remember talking about a fence you
know look what Bill Clinton was the
president I mean there was a lot of talk
about building some kind of separation
and that just hasn't worked and I was at
the border myself several months ago and
I have to tell you they have these areas
where during the monsoon season they
actually raised that these gates are
fences and you know the illegals can
come through when they all are tunneling
through and they're popping up on the US
side I mean you know
we've got to stop the human trafficking
and the drug dealing and and I think
that they thought that technology can
really perform the same function doesn't
make sense because with technology you
constantly have to be watching it well
look you know in our backyards we have
motion detectors that can tell you if I
cats moving across the backyard we're
spending all this money on brick and
mortar and I think it could be better
spent but the deeper issue here is our
immigration policies I mean yes we have
to protect the border but you know right
now the what's happening is people who
are who don't have a criminal record are
being deported that's there's been an
increase in that yeah well they're not
supposed to be here with all due respect
Dennis I mean they're being deported
because they weren't invited they didn't
do it legally and I have to tell you
something very powerful and that is it
was a mayor who just from Escondido I
believe who talked about making sure
that the sanctuary cities aren't
protecting the criminal illegals he
wasn't born here people get it it's
about our safety or am I wrong well I'm
not gonna say you're wrong I'm gonna say
this that there's a danger here of the
federal government conscripted and state
police the local police have to have
discretion in law enforcement
Senate bill 54 in California basically
has stated that if we federalize the
police then we're going against the
spirit of Posse Comitatus and here in
Ohio we have we have a number of
sanctuary cities I agree with the
sanction sanctuary City principle
Columbus date and Lorraine Paizo
overland Lake County these are all
sanctuary places and you know we want to
protect people who don't have to be a
record here illegally you want to
protect people you know what we're
running out of time but I got to tell
you one thing that Dennis what what is
so frustrating is that for all of the
dangers that are consistent with someone
being released by local law enforcement
you would think that people would stand
up for American citizens because it
becomes a danger zone the ones who are
criminals yes but the people who have no
how are they going to get them that they
don't share the information if they
haven't committed
crime they are protected by the fourth
and a fifth amendment really okay yep
we'll talk about that again Thank You
Dennis Kucinich thank you